hi i'm beau carnes with freecodecamp.org
in this course i'm going to teach you
how to make a full stack web application
using the mirn stack but i'm going to
teach you even more than other mernstadt
courses
i'm going to show you how to convert the
back end of the app to
serverless and how to host it for free
in the cloud
so you don't even need node or express
the mernstack is a popular stack of
technologies for building a modern
single page application mongodb is a
document based open source database
node.js allows javascript to run outside
a browser in places like a web server
express is a web application framework
that makes it simpler to code a web
server in javascript
and react is a javascript front-end
library for building user interfaces
in this course we will be building a
restaurant review web app
first i will talk about mongodb and how
to host your database in the cloud
using mongodb atlas then i'll show you
how to create the back end of the app
using node.js and express our server
will interact with the database
using the native mongodb javascript
library
instead of the mongoose library used by
many other mirnstat courses
why use an extra library if you don't
have to next i will show how to create
the front end with react
and connect the front end to the back
end at that point the merge stack app
will be complete
but i'll have one more thing to show you
in the final part of this course
i will show you how to replace the node
express backend
with mongodb realm this is a serverless
platform that will allow us to do
everything in the cloud
without running our own server and with
a lot less code
then i'll show you how we can use
mongodb realm to host our react
front-end
so our entire web app will be hosted for
free on mongodb realm
if you already know a lot about the mern
stack just skip to this time code
and go straight to where i show how to
convert the node express back in to use
mongodb realm instead
let me show you an overview of the
structure of the app we're going to
build
over on this side we have the m of the
mirn stack mongodb
we'll be hosting this on mongodb atlas
we also and then we have the e in the
end this is the backend
node in express you'll see that express
is just part of node and this is where
we're going to be running the our
backend server here and then we have our
react
front end and we'll be running our react
on a local server too
inside node.js and then the client so
this is what people will see when they
go to the website
to our web app so let's start by talking
about mongodb
first a quick overview of the mongodb
database
in the tabular or relational world we
think of things like databases
tables rows etc mongodb has similar
concepts that use different terms
i'd like to make sure everyone is aware
of instead of a table we have
collections
instead of rows we have documents we can
do join operations with the lookup
operator
and instead of foreign keys we utilize
references mongodb is very well suited
for handling data with a wide variety of
relationships
let's have a quick look at the document
model to see
here's an example of a mongodb document
it looks very much like json
we can see in here a variety of
relationships an address a title
here's the different data formats
they're all in the document
mongodb stores data in bson format or
binary json
this provides for a wide variety of
support for data types like strings or
integers
and in our code we're sometimes going to
have to do some converting between
json and binary json specifically for
the object id
okay let's get started creating our
database
you can host your mongodb database
locally but i found that it's easier to
host the database using mongodb
atlas so we can do everything in the
cloud and eventually
we will literally do everything in the
cloud
where our entire back end and front end
is in the cloud
and we can actually do it right all on
mongodb atlas
but for now we're just going to create
the database we'll be using the free
tier on mongodb
atlas in this tutorial so the first step
is to create an account
or you can just sign in so once you're
creating your account for the first time
you're going to have to set up the
account so you can create an
organization
everything's going to have to have an
organization i'll just call bose org
for the project name for our first
project i'm going to put
mern stack so i'm going to
call this the mirnstack project and
preferred language
well we'll be mainly working with
javascript and the mern stack
so let's go past this
and then i'm going to choose this free
tier
okay now we're going to be choosing
where our
our files are going to be stored at and
we can just
basically choose all these default
options if we
choose these default options it's going
to be on the free tier
you probably want to actually choose a
location
that's close to where you're at so if
none of these are really close you can
actually check
some of these other cloud providers and
just kind of pick the one that seems to
be
closest to where you're currently
located i'll just
keep on the default and then i'll just
do create cluster
and you can update the settings
depending on what you need um
you can actually pay more if you need a
bigger
cluster but for now when we're just
learning it's
good to start with the free version okay
after the cluster is created
you'll have to configure it so you can
connect to it so click the connect
button here
and then we're going to have to have a
white list ip so just add the current ip
address
so we'll be connecting to it right from
our computer because we're developing
the back end locally so i'll just add my
current ip address
and then we'll create a database user so
i'll just create it as my name and the
password is
mernstack we'll choose a connection
method
and we'll be connecting through
mongodb's native drivers
so this is going to give us the
connection string
we're going to use to connect from uh
from
mongodb and node.js now eventually we'll
have to come back and copy this
but for now we'll just leave it and
we'll come back and get this when it's
time
when we're doing our code in node.js and
i can just close this for now
and now we'll add sample data to the
database
one thing great about mongodb atlas is
that
when you're doing when you're creating a
demo app or you're just trying to try
things out
there's a lot of sample data you can
just use so you don't have to
do all this work of finding your own
sample data so i'm going to click these
three dots here and go to
load sample data set and then load
sample data set
and this is actually going to create a
bunch of different
data sets right within our cluster okay
after the
sample data set is successfully loaded
we can actually use this interface to
explore the data status
and see what's in it so i'm going to
click on
collections
and then these are all the different
data sets are in here there's sample
airbnb
sample analytics geospatial inflix
restaurants supplies
training and weather data for this
tutorial
we're going to be using the sample
restaurants data and you can see there's
the neighborhoods data
and there's the restaurants data and if
we look at the restaurants
we have a list of a bunch of restaurants
in new york
so this one's called the riviera carrer
i guess i don't know how to pronounce it
uh so it's gonna show the cuisine and
the burrow
and then there's also going to be an
address for each restaurant
so we are going to be using this data in
our app
so let's start creating our app we're
going to start creating our back-ends
so i'm going to go over to the terminal
here i've already created a folder
called
restaurant reviews and i'm going to just
make sure i have the right version of
node
and so that's going to be a good version
12.18.0
and now we are going to first start with
our
back end we're going to start by
creating the back end of the app with
nodejs and express
and then we'll create the front end with
react and then like i said in the final
section we'll switch out the node.js
express backend with mongodb realm
so inside this root folder i'm going to
create a new folder called backend
and then i'll switch into it
okay now that i'm in this folder i'm
going to
we're going to create a package.json
file inside this folder by running
npm init
and then okay we've initiated our
package.json file since we're going to
be using
node here and now we're going to install
a few dependencies
so we'll do npm install we're going to
do express
cores mongodb and dot
env so let me tell you a little bit
about these
so express is going to be what we use
for
the the web server it's going to help us
make the web server
cores stands for cross-origin resource
sharing
and it allows ajax requests to skip the
same origin policy and access
resources from remote hosts the course
package provides an express middleware
that can enable cores with different
options
basically it's going to make it so we
can make the right connections on our
network that we need to make without
that we could have some errors
and then the mongodb dependency allows
us to interact with our mongodb database
the emv dependency loads environmental
variables from a dot emv
file in the process.emv so this makes
development
simpler so instead of saying setting
environment variables
on our development machine they can be
stored in a file
so that all will all make more sense
later once we actually create that file
and i guess the last thing we'll do it
will installed
nodemon so if i do npm install slash
g that means it's going to install
globally we'll do nodemon
and that's going to make development
easier it helps develop node.js based
applications by automatically restarting
the node application
when file changes in the directory are
detected
so we don't have to restart the server
every time we make an update to our
files okay time to create our backend
server
we're going to separate our main server
code from the code that is accessing the
database
also the routes will be in a separate
file
since we will be using es6's import
statements
the first step is to update the
package.json file
in that file after the line main
index.js we're going to add
type and then we're going to set that to
modules
module that's going to allow us to use
the import statements from es6
okay i'll just save that and then i'm
going to create a new file
in the backend folder it's going to be
called
server.js
now in the server file we'll configure
an express server
we'll attach the cores and express.json
middleware
since we'll be receiving and sending
json and specify routes
so let's start by importing everything
we need to import
let me just zoom in a little bit on this
code here we're going to import
express from
express
and then we're going to import cores
from cores now i'm going to import a
file that we still have to create it's
just going to be
called restaurants
from and then the directory we're going
to create it is
api slash restaurants
dot route dot js okay because we're
going to have our routes in a separate
file
so that's why we're going to that's the
file we're going to have our routes in
so let's make our express app so const
app equals express
and that's what we're going to be using
to make our server
and now we have to apply our middleware
so app.use so these are the things that
express is going to use
and that's going to
use our our course our course module
and then we are also going to use
express.json so this express.json line
this in old versions of express if
you've ever seen other old tutorials
they use
a a something called body parser but
that's now included in express
so just doing express.json means that
our server can accept json in the body
of a request so if someone sends a get
request
or a post request to our server it can
it'll be able to read json okay now
let's
specify some of the initial routes
so we're actually going to be putting
most of our routes in another file
but we have to specify what our initial
url
is going to be so since this is an api
the general procedure for api urls
is to say it's an api here and then what
version version one
and then this is the restaurants api
so this is going to be the url people go
to so our or
basically our main url which is going to
be localhost with the port number
and then it's going to then you put api
v1 slash restaurants for our url
that people have to go to and
the routes are all going to be in the
restaurants file
which we still have to make but if
someone tries to go to a different route
let's make a a message that appears if
anybody goes to a route that doesn't
actually exist
so we'll put an asterisk here so if
anybody goes to a
asterisk means wild card if anybody goes
to a route that's not in our
in our route file then we're just going
to return
something
so we'll just return a 404 page that
just says not found
okay and now i'm going to export this
we're going to export app as a module
we'll then be able to import this module
in the file that accesses the database
which will be the file that you actually
run to get the the server running
we just want to separate our main server
code from
our database code but before we create
that file that connects to the database
and starts the server
we'll create a env file to store our
environment variables
so i will save this i will create a new
file
go to new file and then this is just
going to be dot e n
v so this is where we're going to
set the the uri of our database
so we need to get the uri so to get the
uri
we're actually going to have to go right
back to mongodb atlas
so if i click connect then we go to
choose a connection method connect your
application
and then we have the node.js already
selected here
so we just need to copy this url here
so now let's go back to our emv file
so in this.emv file we're going to
create
the variable for the the database uri
so i'm going to be calling this rest
reviews
underscore db underscore uri
and then i'll just paste the uri in and
then i'm going to
update some things so we got the
username
bo and the password is going to be
mergedack and then i'm also going to
have to update
this part where it says my first
database this database
the database we're going to access is
the sample
the sample restaurants database
and then we have to create another
variable called
rest reviews
ns and we're going to set this to the
first database again
so this is going to be sample
restaurants
and now we have to set the port this is
going to be the the starting port that
the server is going to start off
to 5000 and then we're going to create a
new file
i'm going to go new file and it's going
to be called index
dot js so
in this file we're going to
connect to the database and start the
server
so first we're going to just import the
file we already created from
server.js so that's the file we already
created
we're also going to import mongodb
because we're going to be accessing
mongodb
and then we're going to import dot
e and v this is what allows us to access
our
environment variables
now we have to configure env so we'll
load in the environment variables
and then we have to get access to our
[ __ ]
client from
mongodb
oh this would be const now we have to
create our port number
or we need to set our port from our
environment variable so to access
an environment variable we'll just do
process dot e and
v dot and then we put whatever we
specified in our
emv file which was porch so port is the
port number
and if somehow that cannot be accessed
we will make it eight thousand
okay now we will connect to the database
so we go to [ __ ] client dot
connect so
and once we connect to the database
we're going to pass in some information
we're going to have to pass in the
database uri
which is process dot env
so this is our environment variable rest
reviews db
uri so that's the name we created
now we'll pass in the options for
accessing the database
and we want to make it so only 50 people
can connect at a time
so pool size 50 and we'll
set the w timeout to 2500.
so after 2500 milliseconds the request
will timeout
and then use new url parser
is going to be set to true that is added
because the mongodb
node.js driver rewrote the tool that it
uses to parse mongodb connection strings
and because it's such a big change they
put the new connection string parser
behind the flag
so now we're going to catch any errors
so if there's an
error
we're just going to console.air or log
the error
stack
and then we'll just exit the process
after we've connected to the database
and checked for errors
now we can do something then
we're gonna create a function here async
client and
app.listen and app.listen is how we
start
our web server so we're finally starting
our web server after the database is
connected to
so we're gonna listen at the port
okay we're just going to log that
listening on the port
and we're done so we've connected to the
database
and we've started our web server it's
almost time to test out the backend
server
but first we need to make a route so
let's create a new directory called
api so
new folder api and then i can
also create a new file that way and the
new file is going to be called
restaurants.route.js
so this is a file that we've already
referenced in one of our other files
okay this time instead of typing
everything i'll just paste in and kind
of explain
what the code does first we're just
going to import express from express
then we'll get access to the express
router
because this is our route file we're
going to be creating the different
routes that people can go to
and then right now it's just going to be
one route we're going to be adding more
routes
and this is just a demonstration route
so the route is just slash
so just if you just go to the root url
then it's going to respond with hello
world
so let's just save that and now we can
actually
test our program so far uh just so
you remember from in the server.js is
where we access the file that we just
created
and it's going to have to start with
this
so i'm actually going to copy this
because
every route is going to start with this
and then
it will at the end of the route you'll
add whatever's here
okay let's try starting the server
okay since we didn't get any errors that
means we successfully connected
to our database so we're not accessing
anything in the database yet but we're
actually at least connected to the
database
let's go to our browser and check the
the url that we created
so go to the url bar i'll type in local
host
5000 and then i'll do
api slash v1 slash restaurants
and then i'll just go to that page and
you can see right here
it says hello world
so it worked and if we go to any other
url
like if i go to slash nine or something
it'll say air not found
looks like we have a mistake here so let
me go and fix that it shouldn't have
this little
part when it says not found so let's go
back to
our so let's go back to our code
and where do we oh here's where we have
the extra
character there
okay well everything is working
now we will make the data access object
that will allow our code to access
restaurants in the database
so let's create a directory called dao
for data access object
and inside this directory we'll create a
new file
restaurant dot
or d-a-o dot js
now in this file i'm going to paste in
some code and then i'll
show you what all it all means so
let me show the code here
okay so first we're going to create a
variable called restaurants that we're
going to use to
store a reference to our database
and so we're going to export this class
called restaurants
dao and we're going to have a few
methods here's the first methods
and these are all going to be async
methods and this is the inject database
method
so basically this is how we initially
connect to our database and we're going
to call this method
as soon as our server starts so as soon
as our server starts we're going to
get a reference to our restaurants
database so if there already is the
reference if this is already filled
we're just going to return
but if this is not filled already we're
going to
fill that variable with a reference to
that specific database
so we're going to try to connect so you
can see this we're going to
wait for this and so connection
this is we're trying to connect to our
database and this is
the name of our database this is our
environmental variable
and we're specifically trying to get the
collection
restaurants so let's go back
to the mongodb atlas interface and i can
show you
where this database actually is right
from the interface
so if i click on collections here
and we have restaurants and see in this
sample restaurants
section of the database we have
neighborhoods
and restaurants so we're specifically
trying to get
the restaurants and not the
neighborhoods we're not even going to
use the neighborhoods data
in this project
so that's what this collection
restaurants is
and if we're able to successfully get it
then great if not we're gonna send this
error message to the console
okay so we're gonna we're gonna add the
call to this right when we connect to
the
the database for the first time right
when the server runs
and then the other function is the
get restaurant so this is the only other
function that i just added or the only
other method that i just added and this
is what we'll
call when we want to get a list of all
the restaurants
in the database so first of all there's
some options
now these are options that we just
created
that we just made up specifically for
this method
and you so when you when we call this
method
you can put in what filters you want if
you want to sort things based on the
name of the restaurant the zip code or
the cuisine
what page number you want because
there's going to be a lot of restaurants
so you may not want to get all of them
at once you're only going to get
actually 20
at once with this default setting so
it's default to page zero it's default
to uh
20 restaurants per page and then
we're going to put together a query
now first it's going to be empty and it
may stay empty unless
someone has passed the filters unless
we've called called the get restaurants
method with some filters and there are
three different filters that we've set
up
there's the the name filter so we can
search
by name of the restaurant or we can
search by the cuisine of the restaurant
or we can search by the zip code of the
restaurant
and these are three different types of
searches
queries are very powerful in mongodb and
there's a bunch of different things you
can do
now i'm just going to show you three of
them right here but if you want to learn
more about how you can query with
mongodb
check the resources in the description
of this video first of all let's look
at the the cuisine and the zip code
so we're just seeing if it equals if
the cuisine from the database from the
entering the database
equals
the cuisine that was passed in so
filters cuisine
means that we've called the get
restaurants method
and we've passed in the a filter of what
the cuisine is going to be
and so we're actually going to search
for that specific cuisine
where we're going to search for a an
entry in the database
where the zip code equals the zip code
that was passed in
and then this is a little different to
search
to do a text search um we're going
instead of searching for something
that's equal
we're going to search for any a text
search is we're going to search
anywhere in that text we're going to
search for
this name so you can see that
here this is a database field this is a
database field
but when we're searching for the name
there's no database field in here so how
does it know which field to
search for for the name that was passed
in
well we actually have to set that up in
mongodb
atlas so we'll do that later but we're
going to specify
in mongodb atlas that if someone does a
text search which fields from the
database
will will be searched for that specific
string
so we'll set that up later so we're
going to get the filters we're going to
set the query
to be either to be one of these three
queries
depending on which filter was passed
into this method
and then we're going to get a cursor and
then we're going to
await restaurants dot find query so
this is going to find all the
restaurants from the database
that go along with the query that we
passed in
if there is no query if we just had this
blank query and it wasn't set to
anything
then it's just going to return all
restaurants
and then we're going to catch an error
and then we'll just return
that's an empty list and 0 for the total
number of restaurants if there's an
error
but if there's no error now we're going
to
limit the results because it return in
the cursor is every single result
but we're going to limit to restaurants
per page
the default is 20 and then to get the
actual page number we do a skip
so we're going to skip from the
beginning to whatever page number
we're at so we're going to multiply
restaurants per page
times the page number to get to a
specific page of the results
then we just set this to an array
the restaurants list to an array and
then
we return the array
and this can actually be
changed here to get the total number of
restaurants
we don't need all this here so to get
the total number of restaurants
we're just going to count the documents
in the query
and then we can return the restaurants
list
and the total number of restaurants or
if there's an error we just return
this okay
let me save that now we'll use the
methods
that we just went over that we just
added to this file
to access the database from our other
files so let's go to index.js
and in this one we are going to add at
the beginning
that we're going to import that file
so import restaurants
deo from
d a o slash
restaurants
d a o dot j s
so we have gotten a reference to
this file and i'll just copy that
and then it's gonna be right down here
so right after we've connected to the
database
right before we start our server we are
going to
call that inject db
so await
restaurants inject db
and we're going to pass in the client
so this is how we get our initial
reference to the
restaurants collection in the database
okay now we're going to create the
controller that the route file will use
to access
the deo file so let's go
let's save this i'll go to
restaurants.route.js
and we will need to make it so it uses
the controller file we are
about to create so the controller file
is going to to be what is what the route
uses
so i'm going to import
restaurants
controller from
restaurants.controller.js
and now instead of sending this instead
of getting this
i'm going to do restaurants.controller
dot api get restaurants
and that's something we still have to
create so
now we're going to get what's going to
be returned
at this route that's going to come from
this file here the restaurants
controller file
and then this method which we're going
to create right now
so let me save that and then inside the
api folder create a new file
and this one's going to be called
dot restaurants.controller.js now it
looks like
we've got some things in the wrong spot
this dao directory should be
in the back end directory
okay yeah so in the backend directory we
have the api directory
and the dao directory okay in the
restaurant.control.js file i will paste
in some code
and then we'll go over it like last time
so
first we're going to import the other
file we created
the restaurantsdeo.js and then we're
creating this restaurant controller
class
and there's a few methods actually right
now there's just one method
which is the api get restaurants and
when this is
when this api call is is called through
a url
there can be a query string a query
string is how we can
specify certain parameters and you'll
see that when we do a test later but
when you're typing in the the url
you type in question mark and then the
key value pairs that you want to pass
in to this to this api
and so one of the query strings that we
can
that we have is called restaurant stop
restaurants per page
so we are going to set this variable
restaurants per page
to equal whatever value is passed in
through the url the query in the url
so first we're going to check if this
even exists in the url
if this exists then we are going to
convert it to an end we're going to get
this restaurants per page and convert it
to an integer
if not the default is 20 here then
we are going to do the same thing with
the page number we're going to see if
we've passed in
a page number with the url then we're
going to convert it to an
end and then if not
then we're going to get this zero the
page number is just going to be zero
now we're going to do the same thing
with the filters so the filter is going
to start off
with as an empty object but if
we see the cuisine query string then
filters.cuisine is going to be set to
the query string
if zip code is in the query then we'll
set the filter.zip code to the zip code
if name is in the query then we'll set
the filters.name to the name
pretty soon once i get this all set up
to show an example
i'll show you exactly what those query
strings look like
and this will make a lot more sense if
you're not familiar with what query
strings are
okay now we are going to call
this get restaurants that's the thing
that we just created
we created before so we are going to
pass
in the filters the page and the
restaurants per page
and it's going to return a restaurants
list and then the total number of
restaurants
and that's what we specifically made it
return now
we are going to get a response we're
going to
create a response to send to the person
or to sit to respond when this api
url is is called so we're going to
respond with the restaurant list
the page number the filters the
restaurants per page
and then the total number of restaurants
and then rest.json response
is one we're going to send a rest json
response with all this information
to whoever called this url
okay i'm going to save that and now we
can finally
test to see if our backend server can
actually
access the database
so let me go back to my web browser
and then we're going to go to the api
slash v1
restaurants and if i call that we should
see
okay we have an error it looks like we
made a mistake and it looks like i have
a
spelling error so let's see where that
spelling error was
right here okay so
let's fix that so after some
troubleshooting
i realized i have this spelled wrong
this file spelled wrong
someone go to rename and
control there's an r in that word
controller
okay now let's go back to
this and refresh and you can see it
sends back
all the restaurants
now we can keep testing the api right
within
the browser but it's better to use
another tool when you're testing api
so over here i have a tool called
insomnia
now another very popular one is called
postmen
postmen and insomnia basically do the
same thing so if you have postmen you
can use postman for this
i'm going to use insomnia and then we're
going to be making a
get request so go to uh
local shows 5000 slash api slash v1
slash restaurants
and now we can see all the restaurants
on the side here
so you can see each one that has the
address it has
the burrow the cuisine uh we're not
gonna do anything with these grades in
this project
but we have the name here and now
let's check using some of our
filters that we created so in our api
that we create in our server
we can filter by zip code so let's
filter by this zip code c10012
so what i'm gonna do
is put a question mark now a zip code
equals one zero zero one
two and i'll send that
okay look this zip code is zero zero one
zero zero one two let's see if that what
the next one is
one zero zero one two one zero zero one
two so it's all filtered by that zip
code
if we scroll down to the bottom we can
see everything that else that's returned
so we have the page number we have the
filters which is a zip code
and then we have the entries for page 20
and total results
407. there's four 407 restaurants with
that that zip code
and we could switch to page
two so i'll show you how you would do
that
so we can see the first one right now is
a restaurant
called
angelica film center but if i
do and page
equals two
uh let's see i messed it up two and then
i click send
okay now the first restaurant is cafe
and if we go all the way to the bottom
we're now on
page two there's still the same number
of results
and we have 20 per page
so let me zoom in even more here
and
we are going to do a search by cuisine
and then i'm going to do american
okay so american cuisine
american cuisine
and now i'm going to search by
name now this one actually is not going
to work so we haven't got this set up
yet
but let's search for let's see a name
let's see a restaurant name let's just
search for
um food what restaurant has the word
food in its name okay
not found this is the thing i said that
we need to set up
right within mongodb atlas so let's go
and do that right now
okay i'm on mongodb atlas
i'm in my database under restaurants and
i'm going to click
indexes i'm going to create
a new index let me see if i can make it
so you can see this better
here we go so i'm going to create an
index
actually i realized before we create it
we want to confirm that we know the
exact
field so let's go go to see what the
fields are
so we know the only field we want to
search for is the name
field so let's go back to indexes create
index
and then we'll do name
and for the type it's going to be text
i'll review that
confirm and now it's going to create our
index
now let's go back and see if that that
search works so i'm going to send the
same search
and now it works now that we created
that index
and let's look at the names of the
restaurants
well this one's all about food this
one's
feel food this one's king
food so it's searching for the word food
all about indian food it's searching for
the keyword
food in the name of the restaurant so we
have this part of the api
working okay the whole point of this app
is that people can leave reviews
for certain restaurants so let's go back
to our route file
and we're going to create the routes for
people to
post put and delete reviews so post is
to create a new review
put is to edit a review and delete is if
you want to delete your view
so let me add those routes right now
okay so we have router dot route
and so up here we just made a single get
request
but now we are going to be able to make
the post put
and delete all within this one router
call to the router so for the route
review
if it's a post acp request it's going to
use
this method here put this method
and delete this method now we still have
to create those
methods and we actually have to import
the file that we haven't created yet
but i'll do that right now
reviews and then this is going to be the
reviews controller
okay now let's create these methods that
will be called when people go to these
different routes
so in the api i'm going to create a new
file
and it's going to be called
reviews.controller.js
okay so i've pasted in some code for the
reviews controller
i'm just going to review it so we start
off by importing the reviews deo which
we still have to create
so we'll do that right after this and
then we're going to create the reviews
controller class
and then there's going to be three
methods we have the post review method
and then we are going to get some
information from the body
before we got information from the query
parameter and now we're going to get
information right from the body of the
request
so we get the restaurant id and we get
the text
of the review and then for user info
we're going to get the the name of the
user id from the body
and you'll see how all this works when
we test it later and i'll show you how
you send this information through the
body we're going to get a new date
and then we're going to put that all
together we're going to send that
to the ad review data which we still
have to create it's going to send this
information the restaurant id user info
review and date
and then in this other file which we're
going to create will actually
send that to the database but it's going
to return
success if it worked and then there'll
be an error message if it didn't work
and our next method is update review and
it's pretty similar we're going to get
the information from
the body the review id the text
those are the only things we need
they're just the review id and the text
we're going to update
we're going to automatically create a
new date and then we're going to update
the review
oh we also need the the user id we're
going to get that in the body too
and we just send it all all over and
that's how we know if we're updating the
so we get the user id
because we want to make sure the user
who created the review is the same one
who's trying to update the review
and then we just check if there's an
error and return the error message
if the modified count equals zero that
means that the review was not updated
and then we can throw an error here
okay the final method is the delete
review
this is going to be a little different
this is going to actually have a query
parameter instead of
the in the body the the id to be deleted
is going to be a query parameter right
in the url
and then we're going to get the user id
right in the body
now this is admittedly non-standard for
delete request for http delete requests
it's
non-standard to have anything in the
body but
for this example we're going to do it
normally you would do this is
this is just like a simple version of
authentication
this is nothing that you would do in a
production environment
but for this example we're going to
check the user id in the body to see if
it's the same
user id that created the review before
it's deleted in a production environment
you're going to have a little more
complex things you're not going to
actually include anything in the body in
the delete request
and then we are going to call the delete
review
and then send over the review id and the
user id and if it says success
will respond with success or else we'll
have an error
okay i've been talking about the reviews
dale a lot
so let's create that now i'm going to
create a new file and it's going to be
called
reviews
deo dot js
okay pasted in the code for the reviews
deo
it's very similar to the restaurants one
first we're going to import this stuff
up here mainly so we can get access to
object id we're going to have to convert
a string to a mongodb object id and
that's what we're going to use this for
we're going to get three views this is
going to just be an empty variable but
we're going to fill it
with a reference to the reviews
collection
just like before we're going to have the
injectdb
and um we're going to see if if the
reviews already exist then we're just
gonna return but if not
we are going to access the database and
then we're gonna access the reviews
collection
and one great thing about mongodb is
that
it's okay if it doesn't exist already it
will just automatically be created if it
doesn't already exist
whenever we try to insert a document
into it
and then the first thing we're going to
do is to add
a review and you can see it takes a
restaurant id
a user a review and a date and then
we're going to create this review dock
here
and we are going to actually
create a an object id from this
and then we are going to
insert it and then it'll just insert it
right into the database
with the the rest id converted to a
mongodb
object id and then if there's an error
i'll return the error
and then for the update review we're
accepting review id a user id
text and the date and the text is the
text of the review
and you can see that we are setting
well first of all you can see that we
are looking for a review
that has the right review id and also
has the right user id
we only want to update a review if it
was created by the same user that's
trying to update it
and then we'll just set the new text and
the new date
and then return the update response or
return error
and then delete review it's the same
we're going to
get the i we're looking for a review
that has
the the id and also the user id so it's
the same
user that created that review and if so
we're going to delete
that review and then return the delete
response or to
return the console.log here
okay we're going to test out adding
review but first let's get a list of
restaurants because
we're going to need this restaurant id
because we're going to add the review to
this
restaurant id so now i'm going to
make a post request
and then i make it to review at the end
now here's the body that we have to send
over
so first we have to send over the
restaurant
id and that's going to be this thing
that i just copied from over there
and then we need the text of the review
which is going to be
great food and then
we need the user
id
which is going to be one two three four
that can be a string or a number
and i will put name
so the name of the person leaving the
review
which will be oh now i'll just send that
over
success let's go over to
the mongodb atlas interface i'm going to
refresh and this is how we're going to
see
if it got successfully put into our
database
so we're on reviews and here it is look
we got text great food we got the user
id we got the name
we got the restaurant id
and everything got entered correctly now
let's see if we can
edit it so to edit it we are going to
need
the object id number
so let me copy this
and we'll go back over here this is
going to be a
put request instead of restaurant id
it's going to be
review id
and then we'll put that here now we can
keep the user id and the name in there
because it has to check to see if the
same user id is creating that review
and then we are going to change the text
to
[Music]
bad food bad food so
if i send that success let's go back
over here now
this whole uh tutorial isn't really
about
the like the most secure user
authentication methods
so this is just all about how to use
mongodb atlas how to set up
the basic mern stack so if you're really
looking for how to get the most secure
database as far as user authentication
you're going to have to check out
another tutorial so i'm just using some
basic things as far as sending the user
id
with this request and checking for that
so if you want to learn more about
security with mongodb and mongodb atlas
check the resources in the description
but you can see
it has changed to bad
food so we've updated this
item now let's see if we can delete it
so let's go back over here again
and to delete it we're going to to make
this into
the delete the query request we can do
question mark
and then review
or wait wait is id let me see it's just
id
id equals that we'll just delete the
stuff in here and it's okay if you send
extra stuff
in the body just as long as it has the
required fields
so i'm going to change this to a delete
and then
click send cannot read property id of
undefined
so let's see what that means
oh this user this one there shouldn't be
a dot there
okay now let's check this send
and success okay so let's go over here
we will refresh
zero result it's been deleted so now we
added a review editor review and
deleted a review we are getting
close to being done with the back end
there's just two more things we're going
to add
we want to be in the let's go see the
routes we're actually going to add
two more routes to the route file
for the restaurants
so i'm just going to paste these in here
and i'll explain them so
now we're going to instead of getting
this gets a list of all restaurants
we want to get a list a specific
restaurant
with a specific id when you get to that
specific
restaurant not only is it going to give
all the information that you get when
you get all the restaurants
you're also going to get a list of all
the reviews
that are associated with that restaurant
and then
we're going to have a route for cuisines
we want to get a list of all
just return a list of cuisines the
reason why we're going to do that
is because on our front end we want a
user to be able to select the cuisine
from a drop down menu
instead of just having to have all the
cuisines memorized
and the way we're going to populate that
drop down menu is from this route right
here
so you can see these are both routes
from the restaurants controller
file and so we have to make both of
these
from the restaurants controller so i'm
going to save this
i'm going to pop over to restaurants
controller and then we are going to add
so right now we have this method here we
just have to add two more
methods for those other routes so
i'm going to paste in some code here and
then we'll look at it so get restaurants
by
id we're just going to look for a
parameter the id parameter
so a query is is something that's after
the question mark in the url
a parameter is just write something
that's right after in the url
after a slash and then the body is
in the body of the request so we're
going to get
this this item this this id and then we
are going to call the restaurants
get restaurants by d which we still have
to create passing the id
and we're going to get the restaurant
back there's no restaurant we return an
error or we return the restaurant
and then we also if there's another air
we can return that
so also get restaurant cuisines
this time it's not going to need to
accept any parameters or anything like
that
it's just going to get get cuisines and
that's going to return
the cuisines or there's going to be an
error okay that was pretty
straightforward
so now we have to go into the
restaurants deo
and finish that up there this is where
it gets a
little more complicated okay so now let
me just
paste in this new code here and let me
review it so
get restaurants by id so this is going
to be more
complicated because we're com we're
going to be trying to get the reviews
from one collection and put it into the
the restaurant
so first of all you see that we're using
object id
we're going to have to add the same code
that we had in
the restaurants deo
to get access to the object id here so
let's go over here
add this at the top
okay so let's look at how this works
we are going to create a pipeline
so this is uh one thing that's pretty
cool about mongodb
db is that you can create certain
pipelines that help
um match different collections together
so we're first of all we are trying to
get
we're specifically trying to match the
id of a certain
restaurant but then
we are going to look up some other
items which are going to be the reviews
to add to the result
this is part of the mongodb aggregation
pipeline
lookup is only one part of it the
aggregation pipeline is a framework for
data aggregation
modeled on the concept of data
processing pipelines
documents enter a multi-stage pipeline
that transforms the documents
into aggregated results it's very
powerful and i'm only going to touch on
a small part of it in this tutorial
check out the resources in the
description if you want to learn more
about it
mongodb atlas data explorer and compass
can assist in creating pipelines
so from the reviews collection we are
going to create this
pipeline that's going to match
the the restaurant id and then we're
going to find
all the reviews that match that
restaurant id
and we are going to set that to be
reviews
and the result is going to be listed as
reviews we're going to add this
we're going to add a field of reviews
and that's going to be a new thing in
the results
now if you check the description i'm
going to link
to a a a guide that shows you how to
create these pipelines
so if it will give you all the
information about creating the exact
pipeline that you need if you're trying
to do something a little different than
this
okay then we are going to aggregate the
pipeline which is to
collect everything together and we're
going to return that we're going to
return
the the next item which is the the
restaurant with all the reviews
connected
and then for get cuisines this is kind
of the simplest thing here
we have an empty array here we're just
going
to await restaurants.distinct
cuisine that means we're going to get
all the distinct
cuisines one of each cuisine because a
lot of restaurants have the same cuisine
so you're going to get each cuisine one
time
and we're just gonna return those
cuisines and that's all
so we got that saved it's time to test
this out again
so let's just look at our routes file
again
that's not it here we go so we're going
to
test we've tested this route this route
this route this route
now we're going to test these two routes
first we're going to test the cuisines
route
so restaurant slash cuisines
and then this is going to be a get
request if i send for that
and now here's all the cuisines you can
see it's just a list here
and later we can use this to populate
the drop down menu
now we're going to do the id one so
we're gonna look for a
well first of all let's get a list we
need to get a restaurant id
so if i sent oh before that
let's make another review because we
when we get a specific restaurant id we
want the reviews to come back as well
so i'm going to make i'm going to
get the list of restaurants
and get that restaurant id now i'm going
to review
post and let's do
[Music]
restaurant
id and we'll put that id in there
and then we will do the review which is
going to be text
it's going to say nice
and then let's try another one that's
going to say
bad and this is going to be from a
different person i'm going to put one
two three
four six and this is just going to say
quincy
now i'll send that okay now we have two
reviews
and we have this restaurant id so i'm
gonna copy that id
slash and i'm gonna paste in the
restaurant id right there and this time
i'm gonna do a get request
and see what happens okay so we just got
this specific restaurant id
if we scroll down now we have the
reviews look this is
this is an array so remember quincy says
bad
bo says nice so it worked we were able
to get a list of the reviews for the
restaurant that way
now we never really need to get an
individual review so
we don't actually have any route we
don't have a get rid out around to get a
review because we'll we'll never be
getting just an
individual review we'll just be getting
all of the reviews
or just editing and editing a review so
we are done with our backend server
all the route to work and now we're
going to create our front end and
connect it to our back end
okay we got the back end of our project
created with node in express
now we're going to create the front end
so let's go back
to our root directory our restaurant
reviews directory
and now we're going to create the front
end so
here i'm going to use create react app
so
i'm going to use mpx you may have to
install if you don't already have it
installed
and i'll do create react
app and then i'm just going to call it
the front end
because it's the front end of our app
now this is going to create
a basic react project
that will be able to update for our
purposes
now before we start actually actually
editing our files and creating our front
end
we're going to install one more thing
npm install
bootstrap this is a css framework
and it's just going to make designing
our app much simpler
we're not going to do any custom css for
this project we're just going to
use what's included in bootstrap and now
we're going to install
uh npm install
react router dom
we are going to be using react router to
route
different urls to different pages on our
site
so let's go over to visual studio code
we're going to close the backend folder
and open up the front end folder
now in this src folder we have app.js
this is the entry point for our react
app
so this is what we're going to start
with modifying
i'm not going to go over all the details
about how react
works so it's good to have some
understanding about react
but even if you're new to react you
should still be able to follow along
i'm going to be using some parts of
react hooks but again we're not going to
go into a lot of detail
so if you like are really interested in
react hooks there's some other tutorials
for that but we will be using that and
i'll be explaining them a little bit
here
so the first thing we're going to do is
just do some imports
so we're actually going to update pretty
much everything in this file
and we're not going to use this logo
we're not going to use this css
i'm going to actually paste in these new
imports we're going to
import react and we're going to from and
then from react router dom
switch route and link because we're
using react router to
create our different url routes that
people are going to go to and route to
the different
react components and then we just have
our bootstrap here
this is what we're going to be using to
style our whole
app okay in this app i'm going to
erase everything that's being returned
here
actually just inside this div
and for now i'm just going to type in
hello
world we're going to make sure
everything is working so far
so if we go back over to our terminal
i'm in the front end directory and i can
just do npm start
on it open up local 3000 in my browser
says hello world
so let me just zoom in more on that
hello
world okay let's go back to our
code and we're going to start making
this a little more complex
so this file is going to have a header
with some navigation on it and it's
going to have a route
where the main part of the page can
switch between a few different routes
so let's start with our component so
we're going to start by creating some
simple
components that then our router will
load the different components depending
on
which url that someone is going to or
which route someone's going to
so let's open up the file browser here
and then
under this src folder i'm going to
create a new folder
called components
inside components i'm going to make
three new files we're going to have
a restaurants list file
which will list the restaurants we're
going to have a
[Music]
restaurants.js file which would be a
single restaurant
we are going to have an ad
review which will obviously
be used to add a new review and then a
login.js which is the login page
so now that we have that we're just
going to make a
a simple thing for each one right now so
let me just
copy what we have here and i'm going to
go to add review
we're just going to start off by making
something
really simple
and i will call this ad
review and we're going to
export ad review
and then we're basically going to do the
same thing for each with one of these
this is going to be login
this is going to be
restaurants list
and then oh this is spelled wrong so let
me
rename this
and this is just gonna be restaurants
okay so now that we have all these
created
let me make sure they're all saved okay
now we can start creating the rest of
our main
file that's going to be the link to
those others
so since we are going to be linking to
those
other components i made we have to
import them at the top
so that's what i'm doing here i just
paste it in so we're going to import
every view from component slash add
review
restaurant restaurants list and login
and now let's see what we're going to
return here
okay i just pasted in some new code for
what this is going to return
and i'm going to go over it right now
it's going to start with the nav bar
now let me just highlight the nav bar
here now this nav
bar is just basically copy and pasted
from the bootstrap documentation
so bootstrap has all these different
components and suggested ways of how to
make them
and so one way you can do if there's a
component you want you go over to the
bootstrap documentation
you can copy the code for that and then
you can update it for your purposes
so this is just a basic bootstrap nav
bar
and it's going to have three different
links
the first link you can see is going to
be
so it it's all so this is how the navbar
style that's going to be
these different things are different
bootstrap classes
that are used to expand to style the
navbar
the first link is this one right here
which is going to be
the main almost like a logo that the
main the main
brand or class name is nabar brand which
is the name of the website
restaurant reviews sometimes this would
be an image or logo this is just me text
and it's just going to go to slash
restaurants
and you'll see soon that slash
restaurants and just slash are they
going to be go to the same
the same url the same component
and then there'll be two other buttons
in the nav bar
and they're going to be set a little
different they're they're the nav bar
nav so this is the
the brand part of the nav bar and these
this is the navigation part of the net
nav bar
and the first item is just going to be
to link
to restaurants now this link part
that's that's imported right from react
router dom
and that will route to a different
url which is going to load a different
component so if you click on the word
restaurant
it's going to link to restaurants and
then we have this next section
now this is going to be one link but
it's going to look different
depending on our a variable
so it can either look like saying
login which will link to the login page
or it can say log out and then the
user's name the user not that name so it
could say log out
bow and if it says this on click it's
going to
run a function the log out function
and we still have to create the log out
function
it's going to determine whether it's
going to show log out
or log in because of whether
the user exists so this is a ternary say
statement
now in react we can use these brackets
here
to put in some code so
these curly braces not brackets these
curly braces
are putting in some code and the code is
a ternary
statement where we're going to say user
if that's true or false it's true
if there is a user it's false if this is
null
and then the question mark uh is going
to say that the first item
after the question mark is what happens
if it's true
and then we have a colon the second
section after the colon is going to
be if it's false so if there is a user
we're going to return this code if
there's
not a user we're going to return this
which is to log in so while we're
talking about the log
out function we we we're going to
implement the login logout function
we're also going to make a user
variable state a state variable so right
up here
actually right here the first line
is we are going to create a user
variable in the state
now here we are going to use react hooks
and the method is just like this
const user
set user
react dot u state
null
okay so the react.ustate
is a way to to create and create
a state variable that you can use in
your react app and this is going to be
the initial value which is null and so
it's going to set null to the user
variable and then we also have a setter
so we can use set user this is a
function that we can use to
update the user variable later in our
program
so now we have the user variable and now
we're going to create two functions the
login function and the logout function
we'll create these as async functions so
async
function
login and
you're going to pass in we're going to
pass in the user but we'll default it to
null
and then we're going to set user to
user so now
if you call the login function and pass
in the user
this user variable will be updated with
the user that you pass them to that
function
and then we can also do a similar thing
with the logout function
so async function log out
set user null
okay so when you log out it's just
making the user null there is no user
you've been logged out just so you know
for this app i'm not going to be
implementing a full
login system i'm going to be basically
implementing a dummy login system
that's a little out a full login system
is a little outside the scope of what i
want to teach in this tutorial
so we're just making a dummy login
system which is basically a form
that someone when when someone uh fills
out the form they click log
in it's just going to set the user with
that those details and it's not even
going to save the user to the database
or anything like that
this is just kind of a dummy login
system that you can easily
update with a more fully full-fledged
login system
you can maybe even set it up to use
google sign in
or some sort of authentication provider
but for now we're just having a dummy
system just for this example
but we have this login and log out
function
and so if someone clicks log out it's
going to log out the user here
and if they click login it's going to go
to this url
and this is going to be a page we can
log in that we still have to create
but let's just keep scrolling down we
are past
the navbar section and now we're going
to have
basically the the route section
or the rest of the page so this is the
rest of the page here
and it's we are going to use a
switch to switch between a few different
routes
so the first route is either going to be
slash or slash restaurant
and that's going to load this component
restaurants list
the second route is one that i don't
actually need
i was trying something out and i ended
up not he's
deciding not to use that that thing that
last route so the next route is
restaurants
slash id slash review so up here
we do a component equals restaurant list
here
instead of doing components we're going
to do render the reason why
we're using render instead of components
is because this allows us to
pass in the props to the component that
we're loading
so here we're loading restaurants list
here we're loading the ad review
component
and we're passing in the props we're
passing in the user
to this ad review component also
uh we'll be able to access this
id variable from from that
component and then we also have the
route of the restaurants slash id
so this would be loading a spec and this
is going to load the
the restaurants component and then we
have the login route
and that's going to load the login
component so those are all the routes
we have the the route that the
restaurant list
route the ad review the restaurant route
and the login route where it says
restaurant that made me realize that
this should be a singular okay
let's start with creating the restaurant
list
component which is going to list all
the restaurants now a key part of
listing
all the restaurants is getting the
restaurants
from the database we have to get a list
of restaurants
from the backend server that's connected
to our mongodb
database and then we're going to need to
display those in the restaurants list
okay i'm just checking over on the
browser to see how it's looking
and i see an error so it's obviously
it's really good to check
your to check things and test things
frequently to see if you have an error
and then it reminded me of something
that we forgot to do it says you should
not use a link
outside a router so let's go back over
here
and so we had updated the app.js
file but there's a file that we need to
update also that's actually even loaded
right before app.js
which is the index.js and this
is really what kind of loads everything
else and react
so most of this stuff we don't
even need so we don't need the css file
because we're just using bootstrap
we don't need this web vitals
but we are going to need something from
react router
so we're going to import
browse browser router
from react
router dom
okay and instead of this react strict
mode
we are going to be using browser router
so we're going to put browser router
and we don't we're not even going to
mess with this web
vitals thing so i'm going to save that
and then let's go over here
and see how it's looking now it says
hello world so let's test all of our
routes actually so that's the
restaurants list
we have the login that also says hello
world i guess i could have made these
say
different things so you would know that
they're working so
like for instance if we switch login we
could actually just type in
login here if i save that and then now
restaurants
log in so those routes are working
okay well let's update our restaurants
list like i was saying we're gonna need
to get
a list of restaurants and the list of
restaurants
has to come from the database
so we have to figure out we have to we
have to implement some code
that's going to get
information from our backend server
we're going to create a separate file
for that
so this is going to be under a new
directory
called services so
here i'm going to click new folder and
put services
so underneath source we have components
and services and underneath services
we're going to create a new file
called restaurant
dot js and we are going to use a library
called
axios for the get request the post
request
the put request and the delete requests
and we're going to create a some
helper file that's going to kind of set
up axios how we want it to work
and we're going to import that into this
file so in the source
directory again we're going to create a
new file called
http common.js
this will be our helper file okay in
this http common file
i just pasted in some code we're
importing axios
which while i'm thinking about it let's
make sure we install that so let's go
over to
here wait which one this one
we're going to close stop the server
and do mpm install axios
okay got it axios installed now we'll
just restart the server
okay back to this http common file
so we're just setting two things
the base url which this is the url
of our backend server locals 5000 slash
api plus v1 slice restaurants
and then this is the base url and all
the other routes for our backend server
come after this and then we're just
going to set
the header and now we're going to be
able to import this
and make our http
post get delete requests and stuff like
that
more easily with all these things being
set automatically
i'm going to save this and then i'm
going to go back into
the services restaurant.js
and then i'm just going to import that
file that we just created
import http from
[Music]
slash http
common
and then i'm going to make a class
called
[Music]
restaurant
data service
this is where we're going to make all
the
functions that are going to make api
calls
and return the information from the api
calls
okay i'm going to just paste in all of
these
functions that we're going to use for
the different
http requests so the first request is
going to be
for get all so if you call get all it's
going to have a default page number of
zero
and it's going to do a hp
get request of this url now this url
just added this is what's added to the
end of this base url
so this base url is already the url
for doing the get all and then you can
add the page
number also what what page you want and
then if you want to
get a specific id a restaurant of a
specific id the url
is this base url but slash id
and then with the id in here and then
find the find is going to take
three things the query
which is the actual search term or
number
the number if it's a zip code or search
term if it's a cuisine or a name
and what you're searching by you're
you're either going to be searching by a
name
by a zip code or by a cuisine and the
actual search is the query
and then what page number you want so
it's going to do a get request
and this is what it's going to add to
the end of the base url
and it's going to be like zip code
by equals and then the query is going to
be what the zip code is and the page
number here
create review is just going to do a post
request this last review with the with
the data
update review put request with the data
delete delete with and but you're going
to have the id on the end
or get cuisines okay
now we can start creating
our component our restaurant list
component
first of all let's import a little more
things so
we are also going to be using the you
state and use effect from react hooks
we're going to import our restaurant
data service
which is the thing that we just created
and then we're also going to get a link
from react router dom
i'm just going to update this so it's a
different type of function
so this is going to const
restaurants list equals props
so this is how it's going to be able to
take the props and use the props
as part of this function this component
so we're going to use react hooks to
create a bunch of state variables
so here we are we're creating the
restaurants variable which is going to
start as an
empty array and then the search name
search zip and search cuisine
so we're going to keep track of what
someone's searching for on the
restaurant list
and then also the cuisines the reason
why we have these
is because right on the restaurants list
page people are going to be able to
search
for these all these items so we need to
have variables for all the items that
people are searching for
okay i just put in some more code here
that i'm going to review we have here we
have the use effect
this is the way that react hooks this is
the way you tell react that your
component needs to do something
after render so after rendering it's
going to retrieve
the restaurants and retrieve the
cuisines
and these are functions we can look at
those functions right now
so here's one of them retrieve
restaurants so we're doing the
restaurant data service dot
get all and that's something that we
just
created in the data services and then
it's going to
log the data but more importantly it's
going to set the restaurants to be the
response that restaurant
data.restaurants
and so this is going to go into
the restaurants state and we're also
going to retrieve
the cuisines very similar we're going to
use the data service to get cuisines
and we are going to log them and then
we're going to set the cuisines
now we're going to add so this is going
to be in the drop down menu
so instead of just putting the response
dot data
into the cuisines variable first we're
going to
start with an all cuisine element
and then we're going to concat to this
array the rest of the data
so the first element in the data is
going to be all cuisines
so that's going to be the first item in
the drop down menu if you don't want to
select a specific cuisine but you want
to show all the cuisines
so if we go back up here you'll see soon
that there's going to be a form at the
top of the page
and people can search for by name zip
code or cuisine
so if someone searches for a name a zip
code or a cuisine
these three functions are going to when
someone types into the search box
we're going to take the value of the
search box and we're going to set the
name or set the zip or set the cuisine
to whatever thing that the person typed
in or in the case of the
cuisine if they selected it so let's
keep going down here
here's a function to refresh the list of
restaurants
if that's needed one of the times is if
someone searches for all cuisines
it will retrieve all the restaurants
okay now if someone tries to
find something now this function is
actually going to be called
from these functions so someone's going
to type in the name that they're going
to search for and they're going to click
the button
to search once the button is is clicked
then we're going to call this function
find by name and they want to call the
find
and pass in the search name and the name
if they're finding my zip we're going to
pass in the search zip and zip code
if they're refining by cuisine we're
gonna find
by we're gonna pass in the search
cuisine that they selected
and the word cuisine or if they have
selected all cuisine we're just gonna
refresh the list
so then it goes to this find function
the find function
is going to pass in the query
and the buy so for example here the
search name and the
buy is the name so we're going to call
the restaurant data service
with the query and the buy if we go back
to the data services
we can see the query and the buy so buy
would be
name so let's say the name we're looking
for all
restaurants that have the word food and
the name so by would say
name and then query would say food
or by could say zip code and then query
could be
the number of the zip code
so after we get the result of the find
we're going to console log the data and
then we're going to set
restaurants to be whatever comes back
from the the backend server okay those
are all the functions
so let's go really quick over the html
that we're creating
now we're making heavy use of bootstrap
so most of these classes are directly
from bootstrap to help style things
and we can see that we have an input
group
because at the top of the page we're
going to have three
input boxes or or three ways that people
can search the first one
is searching by name and impop input box
which is going to say search by name and
the value is gonna be the search name
and on change is gonna be on change
search name
to so as soon as someone types something
it gets set
as the name and then we have the second
one or well then we have the button so
if someone clicks this button
and on click it's going to find by name
then we have this next section which is
the search by
zip is going to be just like the one we
just saw for name but it's going to be
for the zip so someone can
change the search dip and they click the
button it's going to find my zip
and then the final one is going to be a
little different it's going to be a drop
down menu
for the cuisines we're going to see all
this in just a second on the page
but we're going to select unchange so on
change it's going to do on
change search cuisine it's going to set
the cuisine variable to the cuisine that
the person selected
and to get the cuisines in the list
we're going to use this react function
this map function cuisines remember
cuisines is the list of cuisines
and we're going to map it and for each
cuisine in that array
we're going to return an option for the
select box
and the value is going to be the cuisine
and then
the reason why it's substring 0 20
because some cuisines are very
very long and we want to make sure the
search box isn't too long so we're going
to just have it
just the first 20 characters or is that
21 characters
just the first little bit of the cuisine
and
so people and search the cuisine and
they click the button it'll find my
cuisine
okay now the next section is we have
another row here a row is from bootstrap
and we're going to use another map
function to map through the restaurants
array
we're in react this curly braces
means that it's going to be some sort of
javascript code
and for each restaurant
we're going to first get
the address so we're going to be putting
the address of each
restaurant and the address in the
database is actually three different
fields we have the building
which is like the number then we have
the street
then we have the zip code
so we're just going to put that on to
one string that we can use
and so for each restaurant we're
returning
this whole thing right here which again
is directly from bootstrap and there are
different cards and each card is going
to have the name of the restaurant
the cuisine the address
and then there is going to be a
link to view reviews and if you click
this rank
link it's going to go to this new route
ralph
restaurant slash and then it's going to
have the restaurant id
and then also there's going to be a link
here to link to
google maps so the reason why we have
one of the reasons we got this variable
up here so we can use it both
here and we can use it for this link to
google maps so
it's going to use this link from google
maps and it's just going to put the
address
on the end which is actually going to
create a link
to a google maps of that exact address
and then we have a bunch of classes from
bootstraps and it's going to be called
view map
let's test this out and see what it
looks like i'm going to save this
okay and here's our page so here are the
three different
search boxes i was talking about and
here we can
select a cuisine if we want and you can
see it's cut off like we
mentioned but most of the cuisines are
are less than
those characters and then we can see
all the restaurants and it cuts off
at 20. so we can search by
cuisine if i click search here now it's
just going to show
the african cuisine restaurants
or i can search by name and put
food click search and now all the
restaurants have the word food in them
or i can search by zip code
let's do one zero zero one four and
click search
and now all the restaurants
have the zip code of one zero zero one
four and if i click on view map
let's see what opens here the google map
opens
if i zoom in let's see if it even shows
the name of that restaurant i zoom in
look it says one if by land two if by
sea right there
and that is actually the name of the
restaurant from our database one if by
land 2 if by c
so that actually took us to the map
so let's say we want to go back to all
cuisines
and all cuisines is also means that
you can only search for one thing at a
time so if i click all cuisines it's
going to go back to every restaurant
another thing really quick right now i
do not have any pagination and i don't
plan to add any pagination
but because of how the api is set up it
would be pretty simple to add the
pagination yourself
so you could make something at the end
where you can maybe you would make
something at the be
the end of the data or maybe the
beginning of the data
where you could click next page previous
page and then go through the different
pages
for the front end we do not current i do
not currently have that
in the code but that's just like an
extra thing you could try to
add in but let's go to view reviews
well right now it just says hello world
because so we the route is restaurant
slash the id
and we have not created anything for the
reviews yet
that's what we need to create now we
need to create
what it looks like when you're viewing
an individual restaurant with the
reviews
so let's go back over to our code we are
going to open up
the restaurants file
and let's update the import so we're
going to also import used
stay in use effect and the restaurant
data
service and i'm going to change this to
the other kind of function where
props
now i'm just going to paste in some code
again and we'll review it but we're
going to create the initial
restaurant state which has all the
fields but they're just set to empty or
null and then we're going to create a
restaurant
we're going to use the initial
restaurant state to set up the
restaurant which is just
all these null and empty fields and then
the use effect okay when the use effect
is going to be called
when the page when the component first
renders and
how it has the this array here
with just this the id in the end in the
array
that means this use effect is only going
to be called
if this id is updated so if this
component is called multiple times it's
only going to call the get restaurants
again if this id is updated
so it's going to call get restaurants
with the id
and that's where it's going to load the
restaurant
through the data service restaurant data
service and they get the id
and then it's going to set the
restaurant as response.data
and it's going to log that or else if
there's an error it will log the error
and one thing you're going to be able to
do in here is
delete a review now this will only
you'll only be able to delete if you are
logged in as the user who created that
review
but when you do delete a review it's
going to need
a review id and the index
of the review from the review
array which is the state the reviews
the review variable from the state
so we're going to delete call delete
review with the review id
and then with the response we are going
to set
the restaurant with to be that array
the restaurant array without the
restaurant that was deleted
so we're going to take the previous
state of the restaurant array
and we're going to splice
the index of the one that was deleted so
whatever review is deleted we're going
to delete from the reviews
array and then we're going to return
that previous state with this
spliced array with with the array that
was deleted removed
back into the restaurants array
else or i'm not else but if there's an
error we're going to log the error
now let's update the actual html that's
returned from here
so we're going to check to see if there
is a restaurant
so remember whenever you see the
squiggly brace we're just about to put
in some code
and the code is a ternary operator okay
so if there is a restaurant
well first let's look what happens if
there's no restaurant if we go down this
line here
with the ternary operator if there's no
restaurant
it will say no restaurant selected
so if somehow you get to this
you are this route and there's no
restaurant i'll say no restaurant
selected
but most of the time there's going to be
a restaurant and it's gonna
that's what the so the first thing after
the question mark is if it's true if
there is a restaurant
we're gonna we're gonna put the
restaurant name
we're going to say what the cuisine is
say what the address is what the
building
the street the zip code
and there's also going to be a button
add review
which will link to this route
restaurants
slash the restaurant id slash
review so that's the route to add a
review to that restaurant
now we're going to list the reviews so
first there's this new heading of the
reviews
and if restaurant reviews that length is
more than zero that means there's some
reviews we're going to do something
if not it's going to show you what if
not it's going to say no reviews yet
but if there are reviews we're going to
map over the reviews and for each review
and then also we're going to get the
index of each item in that reviews array
for each review now we always have to
have a key so the key is going to be the
index
for each review we're going to put the
text now these are going to be cards
this is just part of bootstrap to show
cards we're going to put the review text
and they're going to have the user which
is the name the name of the user
and then the date and now
this is where we are going to show
buttons
depending on what user is logged in
so let's look at this so first of all we
check to see
if there is a user if there's a user
logged in
so if there's a user logged in and
if the user id equals the same
as the review dot user id so if the
logged in user has the same id
as the user id of the review
then now it just says and and again
that's just like a
a fancy way uh having the these
ands is a fancy way of saying if these
are true
then we're going to put this code in
here it
so as far as what what javascript you
can put
inside a react like this this is kind of
the best way to do it
you put and so it only gets to this last
part of adding this last part if the
things before
are true so if both these are true then
it's going
to put two different buttons we're going
to have this
delete review button which see it's
going to be delete
and on click when you
when you click it it's going to call the
delete review function
with the review id and the index and
also
we are going to have
a link here and this link is going to be
an
edit button if you click the edit button
it's going to
call the restaurants it's going to go to
the restaurants path the restaurant
slash
restaurant id slash review so that's the
place to edit a review and it's going to
pass
in the state of the current review
so we're going to if we're editing this
review
we're going to pass in the state of that
review so we can
fill in the fields with the actual text
of the current review
on the review page and that's
pretty much it because this is going to
create a
card for each element of the reviews
array
okay we can test that out so let me save
that
go back to the all the restaurants and
remember
we had already added some reviews to
this one just from
from insomnia so if we view reviews we
can see
nice so these are the two reviews
now we can't delete or edit them because
we're not logged in we have to log in as
one of these users to be able to delete
or
edit them so let's click login and we
can't because we haven't implemented
that page yet
so that's what we'll do now okay let's
go back to the login.js page
this is going to be a simple page with
just two text fields
for the user and the user id that you
submit and then it logs in with that
user and user id
remember what i said we're not doing a
full featured
authentication system this is just like
a dummy authentication system
and you would update this page with
something more complex if you wanted to
actually
use this in anything like production but
we're just going to make something
simple really quick
and i'm just going to update all this
with this new page and just go over it
so we're going to you we're going to
have the use date
and then we're going to create the login
component so the initial user state is
just going to be a blank name and a
blank id
and then we're going to create the user
variable which is the initial user state
which is just the blank name and
blank id and we're going to handle
input change because we we have this
form down down here and the form is just
going to have
two input fields we have this first
input field which is the username
and you can see we have the id of name a
name here
uh the value is user.name if you click
on it on change handle input change
and then this is also handle input
change on the id
which has the value of user.id and
so no matter whether you
it's doing a handle input change for
both of these for the username and id
event.target is going to get the name
and the value from the target
so so the name is going to be this so if
it gets the
it knows whether it's the name or the id
and then it's going to get the value
and then it's just going to set the set
the is it going to update the user state
with the new name or the new id and then
the only other thing would be
if you click the login button on click
login it's going to
call props dot login user and then
props dot history dot push slash means
it's going to
update the url so it just goes through
this other route it's going to this
route the slash route
so it's going to log in the user and
then it's just going to go to the home
page again
now you may be thinking wait where is
this login coming from is it calling
this login
no it's it's actually different this is
props.login
so if we go back to
what pages i think app.js
so if you see when we created the
the route the route for the login page
one thing we passed in as one of the
props we passed in as login
was login equals login and this login
is actually this login
so we're passing this function
to the login page so
on the login page when we do
props dot login and pass in the user
this is actually the function
from from the other page from from the
other file
so it's actually passing in the user
to this we're setting the user into this
file and to this
into this user variable and then that
user variable
through these routes see are
passed in to the other routes
so that's how we get the user from the
login page
to these other routes so let me go
and save this
and we'll go try this out so we're on
the login page now so click it log
in i'll put bo one two three
four and click log in now it goes back
to the main page if i click
view reviews here well look we can now
edit and delete this one
because the user and user id was bo1234
for this review
now i can delete or edit let's try
editing
oh we haven't made that page yet the
editing page and the add page are the
same
page so add review
we can try out the delete though let's
see if the delete works
yep that works and let's see if i
refresh if it's still deleted
and it's not so that did not work
okay so that delete didn't work and it
was because we're not
sending the the user id here
so the server is expecting a user id to
be sent with this
and a delete can't send
data in the normal way because normally
most people don't use a body with a
delete request
it's not necessarily best practice but
again
i'm not really focusing on
authentication here but what we're going
to do
to make sure this
to pass in the username is this we're
going to have to use
user id
id and when i get this user id here
this should be user id and now we have
to make sure we
call this with the user id
so if we go over to
where we delete something
we're going to pass in the user id
so delete reviews review id and then
comma props dot user.id
okay let's see if that works
i'm going to log in with bo1234
view reviews and let's see if i delete
enough i refresh it let's see if it
stays deleted
and it stays deleted so we successfully
deleted that review and it's deleted
from the database
now we have to create the ad review page
so let's go to add review here
now i'm going to update this code and
then we'll go over it
so it starts off like the other ones
react review state
the restaurant data service link from
react dom
and the initial review state is just
going to be an empty string
because someone's just going to type in
a string for the review
and then we're going to keep track of
whether this is a new review
or if we're editing the review like
i could have titled this something
besides ad review because we're using
the same page to add reviews
and edit reviews but the default is
false
false we are not editing the review
we're defaulting to adding the review if
we go to this page
so now we have to figure out if this
editing should become true if we are
editing the review the way to find out
if we're editing this review
is to see if a current review was passed
in
to this component
so if we go back to here if someone
clicks the edit review
it passes in this state of current
review
so we're seeing if this state has been
passed in
so first we need to see if the state
even exists and if it does
we have to check if the current review
is part of that state
if so then we'll set editing to true and
then we'll set the initial review state
to props at location state that current
review
text so that's the text of the review
that we're editing
and then we are going to create this
review variable
using the initial review state which is
either going to be an empty string
or it's going to be the text here and
then we're going to keep track of
whether the review was submitted or not
starting with false it hasn't been
submitted and this is our handle input
change function so when someone types
into the text box
it will change it'll set the review to
whatever the person typed in
and i can just i'll just i'll just go
and look at that right now
so first we check to see if there's a
user if there's no user you can't
actually add a review because you have
to be
logged in to add review then we're gonna
ch so this
is a ternary function if so we're gonna
do this
if not so if there is no user it's going
to say please log
in see anything after this colon here
it's going to say please log
in but if we are logged in now we're
going to check if it's submitted yet
so if it is already submitted it's going
to
do this so question mark is it submitted
right after this question mark is the
yes answer yes i'll say you submitted
successfully
and then there's going to be a link to
go back to the restaurant
so the restaurant that you started on if
it's not submitted yet
then there's going to be a form here so
this form
is going to have a description it's
either going to say
edit review or create review depending
on whether we're currently editing the
review or
if it's we're adding a new review so if
editing is
true it's going to say edit review if
editing is false that means writing a
new review it's going to say create
review
then the input form is going to
have the value of the review and then if
you type
it will update that value and then if
you click
it's going to save review if you click
submit
so this let's look at the save review
function
the save review function is going to
create this data
with the text of the review the name
which is the props that user.name
the user id props user id and the
restaurant id props.match.params id
the mass.pram's id means it's going to
be right from the url we're getting the
restaurant id
right from the url here and then
if we're editing
there's also going to be one more part
of the data
if we're editing the review then
we are going to get the review id
and add it to it the current review id
so if you're not editing there's not the
review doesn't have an id because it
doesn't
get an id until you create the new
review review but if you're already
editing it
you need the review id to say what
review is going to be
edited and then so if you're editing a
review
it's going to call update review and
it's going to set submitted to true
if you create a new review else it's
going to create a review
in both cases passing in the data in
both cases it's setting
submit to true it's logging the data
and that's pretty much it for the ad
review
so let's save that and then we'll test
it out
so click on restaurants we'll go to
happy garden this time
there's no reviews yet let's see if we
can add one well wait to log in first so
click login i'll click i'll do bow
one two three four log in and then we'll
go to view reviews again
add review and i'll say
worst
[Music]
restaurant ever
submit you submit successfully back to
restaurant
and you can see here's the review here
also
let's just confirm we haven't been to
mongodb atlas for a while so let's go
check to see if
it's in there so let me go back to that
page
and then we'll go to reviews here
loading which are refreshing
and let's see if we can find the review
i just added
worst restaurant ever here it is
so bo1234 worst restaurant ever
so let's go back over
and we can edit actually now it is the
best restaurant i went to it again and
realized i was wrong the first time
submit that and now it's best restaurant
ever
if i log out i can still see the review
but i cannot edit it and i cannot delete
it
so we can see the list of restaurants we
can
search we can search by kitchen
let's try that word all the kitchens we
can search by zip code 1001
we can search by cuisine
do brazilian
we can view maps
this one seems to be closed
and we can log in
and i'll try different name
how about abby and we'll do four three
two one
now i can view reviews but i can't edit
that one but i can add another review
not amazing
if you go back to restaurant i can
delete a review
and this is basically done
we've created a fully functional mern
stack
app okay we're going to do one
final thing we're going to update the
title
that will be on the tab or in the top
bar on your web browser
so let's go to the public tab here
and then we're going to or the public
folder i mean we go to index.html
and we'll keep most of this as is but we
will update this instead of react
app this is going to now say
restaurant reviews
okay we're done
so we finished creating our entire app
using
the mern stack using mongodb express
react and node.js well
now i'm going to show you that you don't
even need node.js
or express because you can do all of the
backend
right from mongodb realm mongodb realm
is a serverless application backend
that streamlines implementation of
features like user authentication
data validation and business logic with
configurable functions and services
that integrate realms data access and
security rules
so this is the structure of our app so
far
but we're now going to replace this e in
the n
this whole section with mongodb realm
and we're also going to replace this
section
and instead of hosting it locally we are
going to host it
in the cloud so this is what the new
structure of the app is going to look
like
see the back end is now realm and it's a
back end as a service
because it's all hosted in the cloud at
realm and then the front end is also
going to be hosted
through realm and it's going to be the
same react front-end you see the client
is going to look exactly the same
now you can see these little lock icons
after we get everything set up on realm
we're going to have a lot more security
between
the backend and the front end of the
database and the client
so let's start setting this up so we are
going to
completely remove the backend that we
made with node.js in express
and i'm going to show you how to
implement that all with realm
and it's way easier and way faster than
creating that whole back end with no
node in express so we'll still be using
the same
react front end but i'm going to show
you how to just use that front end
with the realm back end and after that
i'm going to show you how you can use
mongodb realm to host the front end as
well
so the front end and back end will be
all hosted in the cloud
on mongodb realm so let's get started
first i'm going to show you how to use
realm to create an api that exposes data
and then i'll show you how to update
data in a mongodb database
inside mongodb atlas so first let's go
we're we're starting in our mongodb
atlas cluster
and then we'll go to the realm tab right
here
okay it automatically goes into the
create a new application
section but if you have already been
to if you already have an application
you may just have to click the create
new application button to get to the
screen
but we're going to call this
restaurant reviews
and then i'll just click create realm
application and i don't need any of
these guides here
okay we got this set up and
realm has a bunch of features and we're
only going to scratch the surface of
what it can do
so you can look through all these things
over here
we're actually going to mainly focus on
third-party services
and then later when we want to host our
front end we're going to go to
hosting but you can kind of play or just
look around in here and see the
different
things that it can do but we're going to
start off by just going to third party
services here
exposing data through third party
services is at the heart of creating a
realm back in service
so that's what we're going to create now
this is going to allow us to update the
data outside of this website
we'll basically be creating the the
wrapper for an api
so let's add a service
we are going to create a service called
http
now there's some built-in you can choose
twilio github aws depending on
what type of api you're trying to
connect
or create or what type of service you're
going to create but for our purpose
we're just
doing an http service and i'm just going
to call this restaurants
and then i'll click add service
okay now i'm going to click add
incoming webhook this is what's going to
expose this service
to the outside world on the internet so
we're in the settings first we're going
to look at that first and this is going
to
this will specify the authentication
requirements and other behaviors
i'm just gonna call this restaurants and
this name
is basically going to be one of our api
endpoints so each
name the each web hook or wait each name
is going to be a different api
endpoint that our front end is going to
access
if you scroll down here a little bit you
can see that you can choose the http
method
we can we have to actually create a
different service for each type of http
method like get
post put delete so the most popular type
is a get request so this first one we're
going to make a get request
this is going to be so we have the
different apa endpoints
we're going to recreate all the api
endpoints from
our node express server right from realm
and the first one we're going to create
is the one that's going to return a list
of all the restaurants
you can also set up different types of
authentication here
or authorization for the request
but since this is a pretty uh basic
tutorial i'm just trying to show you how
to do the basics here so we're not going
to get into
authentication but one cool thing
is that mongodb realm can it
makes it easy to either create your own
authentication
or also hook up with the a google
authentication or facebook
authentication
and so you can use that those
authentication pages to authenticate
for your mongodb realm app we're not
going to
go get into that today but i just want
you to know that that's a possibility
for now we're not even going to
implement any authentication because i
just want to want you to see
the basics of how this works request
validation is important to verify
requests
it helps fight against bots that may
attempt to interact with your service
an easy way to implement this is to
require secret
this is just a git argument it's a
parameter that's appended to the call
then request will only be processed if
they include the secret
but for now we're just going to do no
additional authorization
and i'm going to click the save button
so now it brings us over to the function
editor by the way when you click the
save button it actually doesn't
deploy anything it doesn't make anything
live until you click the review and
deploy
a button so that's where you can save a
bunch of things and then deploy
everything all at once you may have
multiple changes and then you can deploy
all of them
but we're not going to deploy yet
because we have to create our
function so we're just on the settings
tab right here but now
once we click save it automatically went
over to this function editor so now
we're on the function editor
and this is the function that will be
run when someone
calls the api to call this api
or to send a message to this api
endpoint it's just this
url here so this url
is what we are going to use that our
front end
is going to send a get request to this
url
and then this function will be run so
this function
is basically just like the function from
our node express server or it will be
once we finish creating it
this is just an example when you when
you first create
one of these services it will
automatically put this code in
as a function as an example but we're
going to update all this
to create a function that's very similar
to our node express backend
okay so first i'll just show you how to
create
a very simple response and then we'll
make it a little more
complicated so we're going to actually
get rid of most of the stuff but let me
just show you this so this is how you
get
query parameters so payload.query is
going to be these arguments right here
and then you can
get the content types with
payload.headers you can get the body
with payload.body
and then this is just kind of showing
how you would log that information here
so these are all just examples here but
what we want to do
for now i'm going to just delete
all of this here
[Music]
and what we're going to do is just try
to
get remember we're we're trying to
return a list of restaurants
so what i want to do is just get that
collection we need to get access to
our collection our restaurants
collection right from this function
so let's make a variable const
collection
equals when you're creating a function
you're always going to have access to a
variable called
context and if you do context.services
we're going to get the get mongodb atlas
[Music]
now this is just how you're going to get
a your database on mongodb
d atlas and then we put db
sample restaurants
remember that's the name of our database
that collection and the collection is
just called restaurants
okay now let's get the list of
restaurants so let
restaurants list and this is going to be
very similar to the mongodb javascript
driver restaurants
list equals
now we're just going to do await
collection dot find
dot to array
[Music]
so this is just going to create an array
of our entire collection
for this example we don't want to return
the entire collection
let's limit so we're just going to limit
to 20
dot limit
limit and then i'll put 20.
and then i'm going to return the
restaurant list
[Music]
and since we're using a weight right
here we're going to make this in a sync
function
so async and then
we can just click the run button it's
going to open up the console
and then we have the results right here
and if i lift this up here
look we got it right here this is the
list of restaurants so if i just scroll
all the way up to the top
we can see riviera carter
so that's the first restaurant and so
this is the list of restaurants
just the first 20 because we've limited
it to 20.
so now we could actually just put
in this url right into our react
front end and if we call this url it'll
return that list of restaurants
but we're not going to update our react
code to use that url quite yet
what we're going to do is actually just
test this in insomnia
so make sure you save your own function
and then we can test this out so let's
click review and deploy
and the settings in atlas have a
configuration driven approach
so before we finalize this deploy you
can see the settings that we're about to
change
this is also the command you would use
in a terminal or a program so you can
avoid using this interface in this user
interface
but we're just going to use the user
interface so hit deploy here
okay deployment was successful so we'll
go over here
and then i already have the url in here
this is our url right from
our mongodb web hook in realm and if i
click send
it's going to see we have our list of
restaurants right here
so it worked now we're about to use that
same url in our react app
but before we do that let's improve this
function a little bit
we want this function to also be able to
be used for searches
so this api endpoint will be able to
return all the restaurants
but also if someone does a search for a
zip code or
a title or a
cuisine it will also return the search
results for that
so let's go back to our code now this is
our back-end code this is the
restaurants.controller
and we're just going to actually copy
this code
and then make a few changes
and then we'll go right back into our
function editor
and then i'm going to paste the code in
here
but we're going to make some changes so
it works for our purposes here
so first of all first of all let's move
this down a bit
i'm just going to move it just paste it
in right here
and then let's start at the top here you
can see we're getting the restaurants
per page and we're getting the page
from the query parameter well there's a
different way for to do this
in this function here we're going to be
using payload.query
we're going to have restaurants per page
and we're going to have the page
and let's do some destructuring here
equals payload dot query
okay so that's how we're gonna get the
restaurants for page in the page and
we'll have some default parameters
so default to 20 and
default to zero so if it doesn't have
resonance for page if it doesn't have
page
we'll just default to those numbers
and we're going to build up instead of
building up
the filters we're just going to build up
the query
the query that we're going to send when
we do our find here
so wreck that query we're going to use
payload.query
and then we're going to set the query
to equal well we can get the query
right from our other code so we just
have to go
over to the restaurants deo
and this is what the query looks like
for the cuisine query it's going to look
just like this
now bring that over and instead of
filters cuisine
this is just going to change to
payload.query.cuisine
so you can kind of see we are taking our
code from two different files
the restaurants controller and the
restaurants deo and we're combining them
all together
into our function so the next thing
we're going to be doing
is getting our search for the name
filter well let's do zip code let's the
next thing we're going to do is get the
zip code one i'll just copy this whole
thing from here
bring it over and then we'll use zip
code
and then this is just going to be
payload
dot query dot zip code
and then the final thing is just going
to be the name one
just paste that in there
so this is going to be payload dot
query dot name
and to make a text search look work like
this
we have to i already created a text
index
so if you just like skip right to this
part of this video you may not have seen
how i made that text index
but in mongodb atlas if you create you
can create an
index based on any field
where you could do a full text search
for any field
and i did the search for the name field
in our database i created an index for
the name field in our in our database
so we could do a text search of that
field okay so
we develop our query we're going to get
an access to our collection
and then we're going to get our
restaurants list but let's add a few
things here so find
out we're going to put the query in here
because we're going to find based on the
query
and we also want to get a certain page
number
okay because p we passed in the page
number
and to get the page number it's going to
be
skip and then we're going to do a
calculation here
page times restaurants
per page and then
we're going to limit that to we're not
going to limit that to 20 anymore we're
going to limit that to restaurants per
page
and then we keep we're keeping the two
array and then i don't need this anymore
before we send the response we are going
to have to update something
in the database all the ids are object
ids and we want to create
we want to return them as a string
instead of an object id
so we can just loop through the entire
restaurant list and update
all the ids to strings and se instead of
the object ids
so i'll do restaurants
dot 4 each and then for every restaurant
we're going to call this function
and the function is just going to be
restaurant
dot underscore id equals restaurant
dot underscore id dot to
string okay
and the final thing is that we're going
to create this response
but we're going to now call this
response
data and restaurants is still going to
be restaurants list
page will be paged and then we'll just
convert that to a string
the filters in this case we're just not
going to return anything for the filters
we'll just return
an empty object because in their front
end we don't even use the filters we
don't
we don't even keep track of the filters
on the front end and then for the
entries per page we'll do restaurants
per page and then convert that to a
string
and then for the total results we'll do
restaurants list dot
length dot to string
and then we'll return response data
okay let's save this
and then well let's just do a test we'll
run this
it says rec not define looks like we
must have made a mistake up here
somewhere
what do we still have
oh this should be i forgot to change
this payload
payload
[Music]
and then we'll try doing a test here
restaurants is not defined what do we
must have made a spelling error
oh okay restaurants
list for each okay so let's run that
and then we get the result now we can
actually
test sending the print the query
parameters right in here
so let's go to the console
and this is how you would test sending
the parameters you can actually
test sending parameters by using these
right here so it has an example here
so i'm going to send a page
and i'm going to send it to 2 and
i'm going to do name
and set that to
food so now we're going to be searching
for by name
and we're going to be searching doing
the page 2.
so let's try that
okay well first of all you can see that
it returned
page two and if i go back up here
let's see the restaurant names and let's
scroll up and look oh see
this restaurant name has the word food
in it let's see another restaurant name
this restaurant had the name food in it
so that worked
i did this is a good thing about testing
this we can see if there's any mistakes
and i need to notice this this total
result is 20
so it's not well i wanted to return the
total results of this
find of with the query but it's actually
giving us the total results
after we've limited to restaurants per
page
so there's a few ways we can do this
okay so what we're going to do
is just copy this here
come down here and then the total
results
is just going to be okay i'm going to
change this find to count
dot then
num num dot 2 string
run okay good we got the right
total results we'll make sure we're
saved
and then make sure we deploy
and we got that function done let's try
adding this to
our react app so let's go back into the
settings
so let's get our url go back to our code
and then i'm going to go back go into
our front end code
so our front end code we're going to
need to go into
our where is our
http common so here's our base
url we're going to update this base url
and i'm just gonna
paste in this url ascot
and i'm gonna take off this section here
where it says restaurants
okay i'm gonna say that and go into our
services
and then this file
are of all of our api calls so get
all i'm just going to put
restaurants here and then
the search should also work if i just
put restaurants here so those are the
two ones that we've updated
this the restaurants the thing where
you're going to get everything and we're
going
find specific restaurants so let me save
that
okay let's try it and it works in to
prove that it's working
i'm gonna open up my console i'm gonna
go to my
network i'm going to refresh here
let me zoom in on this if i go to
restaurants here and if i hover over
you can see it's our url it's our
mongodb realm
url and you can see the cuisines doesn't
work because we haven't implemented that
endpoint yet so let's implement the
cuisines
endpoint right now and by the way all
the other endpoints are going to be way
easier we started with the hardest one
with all the searches and stuff
well let's test that first so let's test
to see if that works
so let's type in food search
look all about food feel food now let's
try the zip code
search one zero zero one
four search and yep
all the zip codes are one zero zero one
four so that works
i assume the cuisine search is gonna
work but we're gonna have to implement
our cuisine's endpoint first so we'll
pull that in
so to implement a new api endpoint
i'm going to go back to here
and then i'm going to add an incoming
web book so we have the restaurants
webhook
now i'm going to add another one and
this one is going to
be called cuisines
and everything else is basically going
to be the same here
oh it's going to be a get request okay
let me go over to the function editor
now if you're in the github repository
there's actually a folder called realm
that has the code for all the functions
so the rest of these functions i'm just
going to paste in here
and then i can just go over it again
it's going to be way easier these are
all going to be way easier than the last
ones
but all this code is basically just a
modified version
of the code that was in our node express
backend
and i just modified it to use this thing
specific to
realm like the context.services
and basically this is pretty
straightforward we get the collection
and then a weight await
collection.distinct cuisine and return
the cuisines
so let me save that and then i'll review
and deploy that
and now let's just update back in our
react front end let's
update the get cuisines
and actually that should be right it's
just going to have slash cuisines
at the end if we go back to our settings
and we go to the url we can kind of
confirm that
see yeah it just ends with slash
cuisines our main url
ends at incoming web books and then has
cuisines at the end
so let's test that i'll refresh this
page here
and now we have all these cuisines it
comes in
and we can do a search yep we got the
chicken cuisine
and let me just make sure right from
our networks so if i refresh here
and we can see the cuisines is actually
coming
right from the mongodb round website so
that
that web hook is working okay let's
implement
all the rest of them so to see which
ones we still need to implement we can
go back over here
so we need the get one which is
slash id and then with the id
right in there we need the crate review
we need the update review
we need the delete review and then
we'll be done so let's do this one first
where we're going to get a
single review where we're going to get a
single restaurant with all of the
reviews
so click add incoming web hook this is
going to be just called restaurant
singular not plural and this is also
going to be a get request
pretty soon we're going to do a post one
but this one's a get request
go to the function editor let me save
that
you can see there's an asterisk there
now there's not because it's saved
and now i'm going to update this code
again you can just copy the code right
from the github repository if you're
trying to follow along here
so let's look at some of things that are
specific to
mongodb realm we have the
payload.query.id
so one thing tricky for this one this
one uses a
path parameter so right in the url as
part of the url there's this
parameter so it's id slash
and then it's the the id
the actual id then we get that path
parameter
to look up the id that's how it is in
the node express backend
so that's one thing kind of different on
realm is that it cannot do a path
parameter it cannot get a path parameter
it can only get a query parameter
so we're going to have to switch this to
a query parameter
so a query parameter is something that's
after a question mark
so it's in the url after a question
marks me a query parameter
if it's just after a slash just like
this it's going to be a path parameter
so we have to change the path parameter
to a query parameter
and it's going to be a query parameter
called id and so we're going to do
something else in react
to make it a query parameter instead of
a path parameter
but it'll be pretty simple i'll show you
when we get to that point and so we get
a list of the the restaurants just like
before
and then this pipeline this is basically
just copy and pasted right from our
express app
to get a list of all the reviews so you
know we're
we're sending it the rest a single
individual restaurant but then we have
to go to the reviews collection to get
all the reviews so that's what this
pipeline does and then
this is all this information is
basically very similar to our express
app
and then right here we're converting
we're going through each review
and we're converting the date to a
string
and we're converting the id to a string
if we don't do that
our react app won't work with it
correctly
okay i'll save that and then i'll just
do review and deploy
and then we have to deploy here
so if we go to our url it's just going
to end with
restaurant so let's see how we have to
change the path parameter
to a query parameter
so it no longer is going to be id here
this is going to be restaurant
and we're going to get rid of this slash
here because now it's going to be a
query parameter which is pretty simple
we're going to do
question mark id equals
and now we change the path parameter to
a query parameter
so save that and now let's
test it in our browser okay i'll just
use leave this network tab open
and i'll click view reviews
and let's see okay it's getting
our restaurant is coming right from our
mongodb realm
api so that worked and we even got the
review here
so that worked too so now the final
things are
adding reviews editing reviews and
deleting reviews
so let me go back to the list of all our
web hooks
i'm going to add an incoming web hook
i'll call
it review
new and we're finally going to be using
a post request here
instead of a get request go to the
function editor
and then i'm going to paste in some code
here and now we're finally using the
body
so the body of the request payload.body
if at first it checks if there is a body
and if there
is a body this is how we have to get it
from the payload body that was sent to
this web hook
we'll get the text and then we'll have
to convert it
from bson to an e json object
e json is basically json with a few
extra types
this body includes the name user id and
the other data sent to this web hook
so this is something kind of specific to
mongodb atlas for realm but we got the
body
and then we have to get a list of the
review or
not a list but we have to get the
reviews collection a reference reference
to the reviews collection
and then we have to create our document
that we're going to insert
with by name by.user.i user underscore
id
a new date body.txt and now we're
converting this
string to an object id with bson.object
id
and then we are just inserting it into
their database
await reviews.insert one review doc so
that's pretty straightforward
and i'll save that and deploy it
and we're not going to put into our
react app yet let's just create all of
these and then we'll put them all into
our react
app so add incoming web hook
this is going to be the editing one so
review edit
and then this is going to be a put
save that function editor
i'll paste that in and it's
pretty similar to the last one we check
to see if there's a body
and we get we get the body into this
variable here we get a reference to the
reviews
we create a new date and then
we update so reviews.update1
first we have to just like in our
express app
we're searching for the one to update by
the
id which we do have to convert to an
object id here
and we also are making sure that the
user id is the same as the id that
created
that review and then we just have to
update the
text and the date and then we return the
update response
so save that view and deploy
now i actually don't have to be
deploying this each time i can create
all of them
at once and then deploy it but it's good
to kind of get in the habit or you'll
just forget to deploy then you won't be
able to figure out what the error is
okay this is the final web hook that
we're creating and it's going to be
review delete
and this will be a delete request here
and then function editor i'm just going
to paste in the code again
keep in mind there's no authentication
on this function
so this is there's this is not for use
in a
production environment it's just an
example to see how
how this thing would work because you're
probably going to want to have some
authentication before someone's able to
delete
something obviously in a production
environment
but let's just let me just we'll just do
it this way for now and we can see if it
works
so we'll just save and we'll review and
deploy
okay let's update our react app with the
new urls
so this review is going to review
new and an update review is review
edit and then delete review
is review
delete
that should be done let's test it
okay let me log in here
view reviews and review
best ever today
okay submit back to restaurant
let's see if i can edit it and let me
just check the network tab so i can see
where the requests are going to so edit
and the best ever yesterday
submit and then you can see yep it uses
mongodb realm
okay let's see if it deletes right and
deleted
and yep it's at the restaurant view it's
it's the mongodb
realm url and we're able to successfully
delete
so we just created the entire
node express backend all in mongodb
realm and it was way quicker it didn't
really take that long to
to put it all together and now it's all
in the
cloud it's and it's connected right to
our mongodb database
it's just a lot simpler way to create a
merge stack app
basically a merge stack app without the
e and the n
and now i'm going to show you how you
can very simply and
quickly host your react front end
right from [ __ ] db realm and it's
completely free
okay if you still have your react app
running stop that
and i'm in the directory for the react
app the front end directory
and i'm just going to do npm run build
and this is going to create a build
directory that we can
upload directly to mongodb realm
okay back in realm let's see where we're
going to upload our frontend
well look at this section right here
hosting
so click hosting host your website here
enable hosting
now i just have to drag over my build
folder
right over to here okay so i'm just
gonna grab
select all the files in my build folder
not the folder itself just the files in
the build folder
i'm just going to drag them over here
and then they will upload
i can overwrite index.html
and then after they're uploaded i'll
just click review and deploy
deploy and it deployed was successful
and it says your site is in the process
of being created which may take up to 15
minutes
so it could take a little while before
you're able to access the site
but it has the url right here so we'll
just go right to this url
but first let's go into the settings and
look at some of the settings
so you can actually use a custom domain
so you can use any domain you like
i'm not going to go through those
instructions here but if you just click
view
instructions it's going to show you
everything you need to know
to how to use your custom domain
so i'm just going to copy this url here
and look it already works i just went to
the url and it's hosting
my react app right on here and let's see
if we can do a
search how about ice
okay everything that the names that have
ice
we can try a cuisine
that works let's see if we can do a
review
first of all i'm going to go to all
cuisines
and we'll do happy garden
add review oh login
oh one two three four oops
one two three four
and we can edit it
[Music]
and this is all working everything
that you're seeing including the front
end the back end
the database it's all through mongodb
and mongodb
realm and even delete works
it's done our entire app is hosted
for free in the cloud everything
about our mirnstack app is hosted for
free in the cloud through mongodb
and mongodb realm well thanks for
watching everybody
remember to use your code for good